so you're teaching Miller comin I know
Penna contra seminar that actually is
going to be training all the music
department graduate students to teach
both music um and Asian me to come and
it is also combined with a professional
development component which is things
like workshops on the CV writing writing
job market publication and stuff like
that so that's my other class for the
phone in the spring i'm going to teach a
class on music and childhood which is a
new class i'm signed especially for
going to be four thousand suns for both
undergraduate and graduate students and
then the other course i would teach I
mean it's for advanced undergraduates
and then for graduate students while any
graduate student it's kind of an
interdisciplinary cross-cultural
transhistorical class sometimes you can
travel to I published a couple of
co-edited modern time music in childhood
in different contexts and then the other
class attention the spring term
music some aspect what are you working
on right now I just finished a book on a
Jesuit the 18th century was studying
medieval manuscripts of music in toledo
cathedral for 50 years from 1752 1755
and working with a calligrapher who
actually made these incredible copies of
the fact summaries of a lot of
communities go so this was a Jesuit who
was involved in many many different
things but I'm so I was focusing on that
one aspect of his work it started out as
a political project to government
commissioned to transcribe documents
that are have a locksmith that they
would use in negotiations with the
Vatican of Spanish government wagon over
the Potomac River Trail which is
basically the claims of the crown over
physical property both in Spain and also
actually in the New World and but as a
as a larger historical project on the
history of kind of Spanish patrimony and
intellectual and cultural legacy he
became very interested in medieval
liturgical musical manuscripts so my
book is about that it's about you know
medievalism and the reception of the
Middle Ages the development of the
historical Sciences in lightning stain
and about how people interpret in
various aspects of the Spanish religious
in the context of bourbon Spain so
trying to use aspects of the past such
as history of the Visigoths the history
of Castillo history of the city of
Toledo and aspects of Spanish culture
from the Middle Ages in a way to create
an image of which create an ideal of
continuity from early medieval Spain
through to Roman's name as part of a
larger ideological building of the
absolutist stayed at that time for
Humanities I mean it seems I guess of
all the core requirements I guess kind
of the one that doesn't I don't say fit
in but but I guess the most different
from any other kind of college
curriculum you'll get can you just I
mean talk about where you see music
humanities fitting into a student's
rounded education the world in general
and so you mean you think it doesn't fit
in even as much at our thumb does um
that's a that's a good point i mean i
guess i guess the two of them and the
sister courses in a way i mean they're
both one semester course um well that I
was just wanted to make sure I got the
point that the context of the question I
mean the music is very much part of a
liberal education in the sense that what
we're doing in music hum is the way that
people learn to analyze the painting
visually or other hard object in art hum
music hum it's the sonic object so it's
the sound object and so in a way you
could say well music is the text in
music on so that people learn and at
home to read text closely and
stand how to take it for a text they
learned that with music in music oh so
it's in a way saying that text are not
limited to verbal tests texts are also
musical and visual test I imagine that
teaching music home in New York City is
also kind of a boon dude oh yeah I mean
do I can talk just a little bit about
the interaction of the city's offerings
with with the class yes we've had for
many years of program where the core
curriculum helps us bring students to
the Opera core curriculum has
supplemented and
reduce the cost of admission for
students in music comment author
students as well not from our slang used
to be New York City off right now we go
to the Metropolitan Opera so there's an
offer of course by dr. every semester
then students are encouraged to go to
all kinds of professional concerts and
arts link helps see you are it's helps
get other opportunities with reduced
admission fees but I think there are a
lot of student tickets miller theatre
offers seven dollars only thing Phillip
tickets and so we encourage and in fact
require students to go to tons of events
in the city and also they're allowing
campus that they can attend we want them
to go to professional concerts
performances they can also take
advantage of the amateur ones that are
on campus of student concerts student
concerts are not necessarily amateur
that many students are professional
organizations but yeah so there's a lot
of attraction and we have musicians who
come on campus that are actually it's
part of me to come programming to have
groups and ensemble residents every
semester the Jews presentations and does
recitals so it's a professional ensemble
but there they offer a specific program
camera made for me to communities it's
very very nice i wish i was in college
still yeah do another yeah um it's no
it's really it is great so there's a lot
of we really really involves students in
lobbies if we even have although this is
not out of the city this is on campus we
even have a program to the core
curriculum of bringing jazz musicians
into every class from music mom that
wants it it's again very generously
sponsored by the core curriculum where
they actually have their student jazz
musicians but their students there can
also be professional judgment if they're
not just a mature and they come in
everybody who requests an ensemble can
have a visiting guests ensemble for one
day and a lecture on jazz because jazz
is probably music curriculum
has been for six years um so I guess now
we get to the less serious questions I'm
not so where do you live right now i
live on broadway 111 and you're married
in your children mm-hmm she's right
around there look did you from last fall
she is two years and three months and
any pets no did you say that is no I
just show up okay so I kind of have a
love-hate relationship with pets mainly
mainly hey there's some pets are small
enough that I can tolerate them in my in
my building i should solace if i have
pets because in my building there's so
many these little white fluffy dogs that
you're constantly seeing is a little
white fluffy dogs that you kind of you
kind of have a day-to-day relationship
with these little white fluffy dogs and
your daughter hasn't started clamoring
for and yeah when she sees a cat she
always tries to pull its to go yeah cat
doesn't always like that she loves mmm
sooo yeah my mother was allergic he's
allergic and was I thought when I was a
child so it wasn't really there was no
question of having furry pets what's
something your students would never
guess about you oh I don't know maybe
that I used to dance ballet belly let's
go that's the hardest question would you
know that's a good answer to someone you
know off to get out okay and how do you
recharge well I got a GV yoga do do
travel a lot for work I used to travel
on warm because I used to do a lot of
research travel like going to
cops and libraries and recently the book
i just finished was based on research
that actually had finished the primary
research in 2006 so I haven't had to do
much of that kind of crowd since then
and I do go to some conferences but I
don't go to as many as I do I'm going to
want Thursday
it's good temper getting bolder cover I
kind of got you know what you cuz i
don't know i don't even know what your
print on the interview but i did at one
point it was a couple of years ago and
actually happened to be the summer I was
pregnant I totally burned out I was I
was I mean I think I had something like
I think I had eight things getting one
son right it was you know in like three
languages in three countries and five
countries and you know every every
conceivable and I just I just completely
brand I just thought you know I'm glad
I'm and have a little girl home or that
I'm gonna happen I'm going to stay home
now because I just I'm not interested in
doing all this travel and more I was
never one of these it's Tuesday this
must be Lisbon kind of it just it's just
too tiring the oh dude do you have do
you have a favorite place in the world
you know if you're gonna be anywhere in
the world where would you be well I used
to that's a hard one because is it a
place just to go and be for a little
while or pleased to live a place of
Travis to travel to Romania to vacation
too I think it's a tie between Rome and
Madrid I spent a lot of time at the
American
and my first book was on this monster
you can see the bell tower right there
yeah be a 50 and that's an incredible
place a magical place but not doesn't
want to live but a place I will I'd like
I like to go to and then my second book
is on its on this Jesuit woman who'd
written in toledo but his materials
presented in madrid i spent a lot of
time would read doing that research my
love and what about New York tier of a
favorite place in New York City me maybe
Central Park I'm not sure maybe the
young the façade by the river how many
done receber which is actually a recent
development are the one that's down
below below you know Graham 900 street
okay oh I'm like right on the one well
do another one remember that was like
near the tennis courts yeah that wasn't
built them and you know that is pretty
recently built it's pretty I do love it
down there yeah I mean that's a place
that I love to go
um deal what's your favorite food oh
that's a hard one because I like a lot
of different kinds of food spicy food I
don't know you mean like a specific food
or does it could be a kind of food you
can say kind of food specific food given
either one and what are your resume are
you most proud of oh that's where we
want time to think about buca I would
say is a time between the Rome fries I
was at the American Academy room and
then my book award no scratch the book
award is for my first book um but I
think no I think in the end I don't
always believe in prizes because I'm now
been on an over-priced committees and so
that the more committees are on the more
cynical you get about prizes but no I
think the wrong prize so that's a
fellowship to go it's called the room
price but it's a fellowship to go to the
American Academy the world needs yeah is
um is your husband also an academic yes
he's a historian ok does he teach come
here we'll do it ok what's what's my
name is against off Miller you lff
hyphen and OH
did you meet at Columbia word no no I we
met actually at a medievalist conference
Kalamazoo which is a huge medievalist
conference at Western Michigan
University its kind of this anomalous
thing it started many many years ago
when this German medieval is I think
many decades though he's actually since
died but a jury medievalist went there I
guess to teach and got really bored
kazoos in the Midwest and there was
nothing there so he started inviting
people to come and speak and gradually
it snowballs into this conference and it
now has about every year every May
happens right after exams that the dorms
are free so they have the option of the
option staying in the dorms just very
cheap it has about four thousand people
in attendance of all areas of medieval
studies and it expands outward also to
kind of late antique and also to modern
studies and a lot of Europeans go people
go also from Pacific Rim all of the
world it's a very very international
conference in Kalamazoo it's the Sun
every tune on medieval is it's very
bizarre but to any minimalist probably
in the entire world it's a household
name funny it's really we were you at
Columbia the time that you met him no no
I met him I was a student at the time
over in 1991 oh ok Kalamazoo and then a
lot of Europeans were there so ok that's
pretty small make you think that she was
living in dec ok I guess that's why I
keep mentioning that there its
international because he was damaged and
he had he didn't live in this country ok
well what are the time actually know a
number of people who've met their spouse
including someone I knew who's no longer
at Columbia but who was a Colombian
colleague well yeah weird yeah it's
really funny but did a lot of people
there so statistically impossible every
night ok I guess I've met my wife at a
Writers Conference so same thing yeah so
what's the last great book you read for
pleasure we're good
you read for pleasure that's hard
because I've been I was finishing my
moves I hardly read anything that would
I read The New Yorker magazine a lot no
pressure I don't know if I could say I
made a great book for pleasure recently
because it's been it's been a long haul
fittings last book done yeah that's fair
enough and literally I literally can't
remember I've been reading a lot of
great books and primary texts and I used
to I'm not used to read tons of na
French Italian novels but it's ladan
it's been nose to grindstone and I think
I know what it was so what kind of music
are you listening to her what's a last
album that you bought her more
frequently well lately a lot of
children's music a lot of music together
for my daughter and watch we watched a
lot of dvds of ballet and opera so
probably the latest thing that I would
say it's not the absolute least as we've
got it a while ago it is an amazing DVD
of the rite of spring and the Firebird
of Stravinsky with wonderful week
instructions of the original
choreography and fantastic orchestra
performance and so and that that I
really enjoyed both as a DVD n to listen
to um thanks you know sir do you have a
recommendation for something to see so
like a something that see you listen to
me in New York City that you know I
guess a concert it's coming up yeah
coming up over this would be printed in
July a princess so it's kind of hard but
uh yeah because i actually just noticed
something that i saw a reference to
something in may that i would recommend
though i don't think that so that's
probably not what you have
you mean how could I can it be something
in general yeah yeah because for
instance there's something that people
don't know about for instance concert
series of early music that are really
enjoyable one of them is at the
cloisters and in a beautiful chapel at
the cloisters and there's our weekends
and you can find those on the website of
the museum metronome museum and the
other is a concert series at Corpus
Christi church 120 first that a lot of
people don't know but i've had my
students I've assigned it to my students
to go to certain concerts there and they
have really interesting early music
groups and programs that are really
really diverse and fun so actually those
are both sort of in the neighborhood but
those are two things that I've recommend
okay I don't I think that's it that was
fairly painless at home oh yeah oh great
okay sure I just wish I could think of
the last time i did it kind of me kind
of